yes
hello everyone hopefully you are seeing
this because
we have been in tech hell for the last
20 minutes but welcome to
the first of a week full of many
amazing streams coming to you from
gamespot.com as we try
and raise money for ablegamers we've
already killed two minutes we're two
minutes late so i'm going to jump
straight in but i'm going to give you
the quick spiel
we're joined by ben jenker and ben
jenkins cam oh
he just came on that plan mr square and
uh you might not be able to see him
because he's wearing his
uh stealthy outfit but we're also joined
by jake baldino
i'm actually cosplaying as you i'm and
i'm cosplaying
i'm cosplaying a snake so uh we're all
like a
a uh a chain of cosplayers
uh a human centipede of cosplayers as it
were
so for people don't know we're all
massive metal gear fans
so we thought why not get together and
um
play the game together and raise money
for uh ablegamers
using uh the link tinyurl.com play for
all 2021.
the twist is gonna be we'll see how good
this works we came up with a hair brain
screen
scheme we'll see how good we are at so
i'm going to play the game and at
various moments
i am going to ask either ben or jake to
look away from the screen
and i'm going to skip the dialogue so
they can't hear it
and then i'm going to feed them the star
of the line
in this game and they will have to
either try and remember it
or if they can't improvise the line
improvise something around the line
we'll see how it goes
it's going to be a lot of that yeah but
uh but uh
we'll do it as a test you know we claim
to be massive metal gear fans
so i i definitely know there's certain
lines in here that i can recite
but we'll see how how well we're doing
how well
exposed ready for it
then when was the last time you replayed
oh
god maybe like a year or two ago i tried
to play the series once a year at least
but i've been really falling off of it
unfortunately okay we're on the same
page yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's been it's been a little while since
i've done a full playthrough
so i just i did one uh late last year
when i
when i started streaming um i did this
game to start with
so mine's fairly recent
you're fresher fresh yeah i should say
we're playing the pc version
of gog which is just a hot steaming pile
of mess
it is insane
oh boy i think this is just straight up
yeah it's
as you downloaded it okay so we all
missed it but liquid snake just
described
what he was going to do do you remember
what it was
he'll be through here i know he flies
that's the one
i'm going to swat down some bothersome
flies
it's in the bag snake
colonel can you hear me can you hear me
situation snake looks like the elevator
in the back is the only way up
just as i expected i worry about people
experiencing the game for the first time
yeah
this way so you need to contact me by
codec
uh i was gonna say i i will i will
announce in advance who's gonna do it so
the next
next skip that i do is going to be for
ben
uh here we go ready and the other thing
i'll say is like uh
donation incentives if you donate 15
or more you can think of this as like a
crap version of metal gear cameo
just leave a line a bit of text that you
want to be said
along with who you want to say it and
the character voice that you want to set
in
and uh i assume jake you're okay with
this i didn't really ask
no mailing no mailing no mailing
um but we will do like a crap cameo
version
so for example if you want me as a
liquid voice to say
uh i don't know it is it's
give me someone give me a line someone
give me a line to say
there you go nailed it that's my liquid
snake
this guy is not leaving what's he doing
he's usually not hanging around this
this much this is a feature of the gog
version yeah this is yeah the guy just
walks back and forth all the time
different pathing
is this shout out there is a pretty good
mod community out there
uh that it takes a little digging to
like get the proper files but there's a
pretty good
like re re-collection kind of
rejiggering of the of the pc version
that makes it
much better i probably should have
texted you about that
uh okay ben look away from the screen oh
geez
so the first line is snake so the line
all right it's that the conversation was
too short he's like this that's right
right he's like
we can hit it again he's like full
there's an elevator take it and then he
just bounced
ah the classic line for colonel campbell
take the elevator up snake what are you
doing
yeah i can't remember what button it is
is it
oh uh oh wait no you've got you've got
to wait for it to come down first don't
you yeah you gotta hide behind the wheel
yeah yeah yeah give it some time
yes scratch your back scratch your back
scratch your back so is that
that route i took from the left is that
the one you always take i have never
seen
the middle to the bottom right of this
map in my life
i've never been there and it scares me i
don't know what's out there
it could be anything true now
remember some more baddies come out of
here yeah so
be prepared and they come really close
to the forklift as well
uh remember weapons and equipment osp
which means on-site inside procurement
yeah you start with nothing
but your bare hands but that's all you
need just a punch punched kick
we're out all anyone ever we did it
nailed it perfect i get to watch this
really awesome like slow motion
undressing
the i call it the disrobing scene yeah
ben i think we've got a few donations
already so would you mind reading them
out
man let me let me get a refresher on
this so you can check it out
that's our boy god
love him uh maddie tompkins gave us
twenty dollars
hey thank you i appreciate that
uh wesley radcliffe with twenty dollars
and uh right now that's that's uh so far
where we are to
today but uh
people keep coming in we got that that
bad cameo request stuff going on yeah
uh this is just the start of this today
we got two hot hours
of this nonsense i would say sorry
but i'm not at all i'm just excited
thank you guys for having me for the for
the first one i feel i feel so honest of
course man
you got you got to set it off on the
right foot melke jake
you love it they're calling this you'd
love to see it
look how he's got like an eighteen pack
abs like and he
runs as fast as he can running out of
that elevator snake
ready ben look away from the screen okay
all right
uh so
uh snake says i'm in front of the
disposal facility
and then campbell plays pays him a
compliment
do you remember what the compliment is
can you say the compliment
so this line actually changes depending
on how quickly you get up there so i'm
gonna say you did it pretty quick he
said age hasn't slowed you down
one bit nailed it you'd love to see it
if you take too long he's like dang
snake you're slow as hell
[Laughter]
perfect okay so you get it you get it
uh follow follow up don't look at the
screen
okay two kind of fighter jets take off
from galena and they are headed snakes
away
do you remember the model number of the
uh fighter jets
it's instinctively i want to say it's
like a like a 16 or an 18.
i'm going to say i'm going to say 16.
but there is
a lot about battlefield there's a letter
in front of it
oh it's it's f it's f wow you got it
f-16s yeah
i truly love to see it a lot about
battlefield recently so i've been
thinking about
f-16 fighter jets i guess
colonel what's the right what's hiding
in this kind of weather he get that one
for free yeah
no idea but it looks like our little
diversion got their attention
now is your best chance to slip in
they can't stand they should not be able
to stand that close
no that's real dangerous that's a huge
helicopter
that's why they're genome soldiers yeah
yeah what'd you expect guys they're like
jake look away from the screen there are
only 18 hours left until their deadline
got to hurry wow you must be crazy to
fly behind in this kind of weather
okay that's the last line you'll hear
snake says who's that
and then campbell says oh sorry i
haven't introduced you yet
uh yeah
no i'll skip that one she designed your
codec contour if you're
nice to meet you snake she says nice to
meet you snake
and then pays a compliment to snake
what does she say oh
what does she say to him yeah she calls
her cute
yeah he says i didn't expect the
communications person to be so
cute she says
um uh be sure to
uh no uh the legend i can't believe i'm
talking to the legendary solid snake
oh so close that's that's good
i mean like i'm willing to accept that
it's it was it's an honor to speak to a
living legend like yourself
that's true and then say that and then
the time the cute line
yeah this this is actually a really
interesting time for doing all these
lines because
you've got the twin snakes lines then
you've got these lines and you've also
got the
the ego raptor like yeah yeah which are
legendary yeah i think you said the ego
raptor one which
the game yeah that's why i was like i'm
willing to allow it
oh that's wonderful i've watched it too
many times it's like ingrained in my
yeah
hiding the cigarettes in my stomach yeah
yeah yeah
and the blue cone shape represents
you're that ninja
be careful snake
they only have like the first video game
vision you've ever experienced
otherwise they're not not good at all
yeah they're basically blind outside
whatever information they see in cones
if he's alive that is
snake your radar isn't affected by the
weather but if you're discovered by an
enemy you won't be able to use it ben
you're up next
oh here we go all right i'm stealing my
whole body for this
you won't be able to use it in an area
with strong harmonic resonance
so be careful we'll be monitoring i'm
not even going to tell you when i'm
going to spring it on you just
that's what i mean i'm steeled i'm sick
i'm like i'm locked in place
hold your breath seriously snake we're
here to back you up so call if you need
some information or advice
you're also in charge of your mission
data contact me if you want me to record
your current status
my frequency is 140.96
i should have quizzed you on the
frequency
you need to arm yourself with whatever
weapons you can find
i remember first i'm strip searched by
dr naomi here and then all my weapons
are taken away
look away from the screen ben okay
imagine putting imagine yourself in that
position
naomi naomi naomi comes in and
makes a flirty comment do you remember
the flirty comment
if you don't remember it you got an
improvised one
so he says he says imagine being you
imagine yourself being put in that
position being strip searched
and then naomi says well the first word
is well
uh i think she
she offers to return the strip search in
kind if i if i remember
right like definitely i will hit you
back up with that
so you need to you need to either say
the line or improvise a line as naomi
um that was pretty good improvise if
if you make it back i'll definitely do a
strip search on you
big guy
[Laughter]
that's not it what hey i almost was
it almost the line is well
if you make it back in one piece maybe
i'll let you do a strip search on me
there it is jennifer hill
love it i'll hold you to that doctor
okay and then he's like i boofed i
boofed the cigarettes
[Laughter]
if you want to get in what entry point
do you guys usually use oh to the right
pineapples get out of here
what about the air duct near the door
zooming in on a fence
that was the first way i used to take
because i was like oh that's the one i
can actually see
uh and then i learned better now i'm a
top
top level guy yeah when i was younger i
would just watch all of these
and be like yes yes what am i going to
do
so many options see a way course of
action like i'm like all in i'm like
yeah let's do it
yeah yeah yeah uh while we make it to
our chosen uh
infiltration point please remember you
can donate via tinyurl.com for slash
play for all
please donate generously all money goes
to ablegamers
a uh organization that makes
gaming easier and possible for people
with disabilities
not not just through like creating
custom hardware but also educating
um they have like design and development
tracks as well oh god
what prints are these cameras
a surveillance camera oh man i would
have gotten that one
yeah yeah uh we do have
some more uh donations too if you're
feeling like nice yeah let's go let's go
all right so we've got a few from
anonymous for
for ten and five dollars uh so that's
good
we've got alessandro fellari gave us
twenty dollars
hey snake in all capitals
love that guy he didn't request that he
didn't request a bad cameo though
he could have he could have snake in all
capital letters so i just gave him that
uh uh hassan said uh five
uh five five six the five five sixers
and pineapples as a note
so that's very good and clever yeah
that's very good
i like that uh a classy donation macho
man gave five dollars
randy savage uh that's the one
oh yeah
oh yeah baby jake the snake playing my
favorite game of all time
literally looking uh at the case right
now while i watch
hope the gaming goes well all snake
snake snake
a lot of cat a lot of snakes going on
never forget the third one
it's very important and you got to put
it in all capital letters and it's got
to have multiple letters
you got to go all in i had to like hold
myself from yelling too much
i'm not being rude here but this guy's
not he's not following his normal
pattern
that's the dog version man i told you
special features
like he's not moving from there
there go oh okay okay you could give him
a good a good warm up
dude he was he was stuck for a while
there
yeah that was oh come on
what's he doing i've never seen this
before this is wild
you got it he's not behind me
give him the the track i have never seen
this enemy do this
the square tap i was gonna go
oh look at that he's just like fully
just
he's locked down he's locked it down
that is wild sorry dude
time to give him the flip yeah yeah yeah
jake you're up you ready
yes i won't look
so snake ass master what are you doing
here and
and liquid oh no sorry i mean uh
mcdonald miller gives a
give snake his life story what has he
been doing
uh since they last interacted
ah he's been he said he said
he said he stopped doing something and
then he gave a reason for why
he stopped teaching to go live in a
cabin
so is that right so what so what's the
what's the line you want it to be read
as
um so you have to say as liquid
okay yeah uh teaching to go live in a
log cabin anyway follow the rats
go follow the rest yeah yeah yeah i gave
up teaching to live in a log cabin
anyway snake
follow the rats so that's what you're
his saying it's like being a drill
instructor so i moved out here for some
peace and quiet
i'm in retirement just like you okay
did you did you get lost in these yes
i got a bad tv yeah i got i used to get
lost in here all the time and now
playing it as an adult i'm like this is
like the most linear thing i've ever
seen
it's like mind-boggling
one that's over the the uh the holding
cells and it's got the multiple
routes yeah yeah yeah that that one
not worth breaking off to find like
whatever ammo yeah or else was at the
end of it
there's also that one that's like
briefly underwater where i was like oh
i'm gonna die and then you come out here
i'm starting like
it's fine as soon as they're done
spraying
also keep your eye on that woman in the
cell a woman
cares feelings
the classic repeated line to make sure
the person playing makes note of it yeah
yeah snake's big on that the amount of
times he just rephrases it as a question
i still think my favorite one might be
when someone's like you've got to go to
the first floor basement ventilation
shaft
the first floor basement ventilation
shaft
like yes you see a hard time believing
it any normal person would
like target the phrase ventilation shaft
and be like that's weird i need to
repeat that
but my man goes for the entire line he's
like first of all he's my friend
it's like he's never heard of a first
floor basement before
here we go ben you're up are you ready
oh man this is the big line this is the
big line
this is like avengers level line yeah
is it gonna play again i went past it
oh no call him up see what he says
usually it plays again yeah usually it
keeps going
colonel i'm stuck help colonel
colonel how do i get down help
you ready ben yeah oh there we go
he didn't do the follow the line it was
no leading just tell me what's
i know where we're at and i know what
he's going to say say it say it you know
you want to say it
press the action button to go down hey
whoa it's right there there it is
batman would never uh get out of here
luke i am your father it's i am iron man
and it's
press the action button to drop down as
far as i'm concerned i just
imagine um like kojima sitting at his
desk
like pen quill in hand just writing the
game
and like he's just been like absolutely
battling with
writer's block the entire time how do i
get this player down this
mother in hole and then just looks down
and then writes press the action button
and then just
dawns on him he puts his quill down and
just backs away from his desk like
i've done it i've done it perfection
this is the first time you have to use
tools or you could use tools if you want
yeah it's a little tricky is it chaff
or shaft chaff is what i always said
and as a kid i didn't know how to read
so i said rations and i believe it's
rations
russian so did i ever tell you my um
my back of the box kodak story
i would love to hear it yeah uh so
obviously to ring up merrell you need to
use the uh a screenshot that is placed
on the back of the metal gear solid box
to read um the the codec number
however yeah as you can see jake uh very
kindly showing us
however that is difficult to do when
your game
is uh written onto a cdr verbatim disc
because you're a child and a dirty
pirate
oh mamma mia like
the confusing thing is also clash of
kojima
there's an item in the game called cd
case
which is an absolute macguffin so i'm
like
looking at this item being like what the
hell what is going
on what what they're getting up here
they've got their supervision how did
they get up there
why was there two of them up there they
laid you out
oh it's because i was running on the
floor uh
oh yeah because i was telling my story
yeah
oh my god um so yeah almost lost it
again this is someone lost again yeah
so i did not have a an image of
merrell's codec on the back of my desk i
had just the instructions on how to
write music to a data cd
um so what i ended up doing was i put on
a pair of slippers and ran down to like
my local game store
and uh and like looked at the disc there
wrote it down
and then ran all the way back home
that's amazing
kajima thinks he can get over me proper
journey that's great
oh man
so i actually don't know how quickly i
picked up on it being the actual cd
case i don't even remember yeah how do
you even know that
especially when there's an item called
cd case in the game look on the back of
this game case cd case
my struggle with it was that i actually
had vr missions first
oh
so i just played and obsessed over vr
missions and i was like i'm ready
i'm ready for metal gear i'm trained i'm
ready to go and i finally like got
enough money to
to buy it and i was still terrible at it
because it turns out that the vr
missions do not train you
not one no shooting shooting targets
with the missiles
your emissions is a wild trip
uh yeah especially when you with the big
one big
big soldiers yeah yeah yeah i'm playing
another ninja
what's the bigger what's the big big
genome soldier called genola
is it genola it sounds right
it sounds right to me too i'll take it
granola genola
granola my favorite soldier uh
i remember them bringing them back for
uh first substance too which was really
nice
did that there's like
in the in the snake tails and i think
for a couple of the vr missions that
were packed into it
there's a weird there's a darpa chief
donald anderson yeah there's a weird
glitch here where you can like
back you can like you can like back
through a wall and get into it
into another part of the game yeah some
gtu stuff
yeah yeah so do you know that
another kojima breakthrough moment in
his writing career if you want to go up
or down the ladder just press
the action button by the ladder cheers
mate so do you know the uh
the uh the merrell thing with this
ladder
yes i do i i know it very if you're if
you're a dirty boy
you can uh i don't even i don't even
know if i want to explain it because
jake it seems like you don't know it
i don't know it you oh snap so if you
do it now no we cannot do it we get tos
and we'll get
banned off twitch and youtube
i just got excited so uh uh
merrell obviously is is doing setups
here i think it's
20 times if you go up
it's it's like four or five no i thought
it's way more than that
uh i thought it's like 20. it goes
through like three different animations
oh okay so the dirty one you go
up and you come to merrell and you look
down at her
and if you do it three times on the
third time she's not wearing any
underwear
oh yeah okay i do remember that
yeah cause like she she does the the
crunches and then you go back out and
then she
come you come back and she's like doing
push-ups and then you do it again and
she's doing something
if we get a thousand dollar donation in
the next five seconds we'll do it
[Laughter]
oh look it's a mirror jake's
jake is that merrell wow i love how i
love how it looks like oh that's
fantastic it
genuinely looks a lot like metal gear
solid four merrell so like yeah
the bandana incredible it's very good if
that doesn't earn a donation i don't
know what will
wow we're already at 180 dollars
that's more more donations if we want to
talk overall yeah do it
don't achieve stuff all right so we've
got uh
brandon hernandez dropped five dollars
and says love gamespot thank you brandon
love you very much and we appreciate it
uh i'm here
we got uh kirsten bates gave twenty
dollars to love you guys
thank you love you too appreciate the
uh derrick wall gave 20 and said love
this stuff thank you
thank you for the donation you're great
and amazing
all of you anonymous gave 25
and niles gave twenty dollars as well oh
thank you
you guys are too good we want to unreal
do we want to skip this because this is
a feature-length movie first i want
something extra yeah
anytime the war footage comes in you
know
when it starts to look like hbo you're
like all right that's enough
naomi the chief ben look away from the
screen
i was about to say that it looked like a
heart attack but yeah what's next
what let's see what am i doing uh ah you
knew the line
did i actually do it before yeah you did
the you did the line before i
even said it ah i'm i'm so ready for
this
you're ready yeah okay i love it so much
you did it you did it
there's a whole bunch of good ones
coming up too there is but we can't we
can't say
we can't stop this one so maybe i'll try
and pre-empt it
get the uh okay okay let's see
ben in the in incoming combat sequence
uh snake gives merrell a direction
what does he say uh
don't like it like a direction direction
or an order
he gives her an order uh don't just
stand there shoot
all right let's see if it's correct
that's that's the only thing i can think
of oh you can lean up against the wall
to the right you can actually see her
yeah yeah i like that that's so cool
also you can if you crouch by the darpa
chief it gives like a cool
cinematic angle like like you're
investigating him
it should work oh maybe not okay well
not that no
no like
yeah there we go yeah investigating so
cool
that's what this is what the kids on the
internet do right that's what we do
yeah all right got him
i do want to get one more view of of
this though oh
that is a bad angle that looks wrong
that's real bad
okay so ben was what was it what was
your what was your uh
attempt at it the line don't just stand
there
shoot i seem from my memory
i think it's object what do you know
what the line is
uh no he's got underwear on in this one
yeah they're
on fire i'm a human oh wrong game
see from my memory it's don't think
shoot i think he says a couple of things
yeah so let's see which one breaks where
more enemies come in
what are you waiting for we didn't pick
up the socom so he's going to stop his
gun with his hand yeah that's great
your hands are shaking i didn't pick up
the cell calm down
oh i didn't oh no i died off again in
the so-called
didn't i oh [ __ ] look in your eyes
let's go lads no kill run that cool
cutscene
that's good perfect too much
you haven't even taken they thought of
everything i told you i'm no rookie
i know what i'm doing snake
wait so how do you do this without a gun
oh they they just give it to you
okay
looks like we'll be a little bit well
you have
it might be twin snakes don't get
nervous
uh so i'm playing on the xbox controller
on the pc and the uh
configuration is real real bad god help
you
oh my goodness i see that did you see
that
cause that was the warm-up that was the
warm-up the aiming on this controller is
like so difficult
all right
it's true twin snakes was a wild time
what a ride
i'm glad i played it for the spectacle
but i never would be like
you need to play twin snakes if you're
playing metal gear i've got a copy of it
here which i've literally never taken
out of the packaging
oh i have a couple of those yeah weirdo
i don't know why i collect twin snakes
specifically less good one
okay okay you got this
yeah yeah what are you waiting you got
the rations at the ready
i'm telling you i'm telling you shoot
i'm telling you to shoot there's three
orders that happen in this scene
little does she know that's not johnny
in the back is it
it i mean he's got his underwear on so
i'm gonna say no
um bullets
welcome to my kill zone heck yeah
i forgot to give you those elite guards
like right out of the start like you got
to fight the scary guys
these they're not very well trained they
don't check their corners very well
no they're merrell merrell literally a
grenade at your feet
she take it she's she's strong she's got
it
nice i am looking respectfully time
it's important for the plot yeah i just
it's
that's how it goes i am looking
respectfully for future endeavors
[Music]
jake in a moment psychomantis appears
what does he say
that is a good mask as well you can
becoming every character in melga
a one-man medal like this and you love
to see it that's really cool
yeah here it comes
you got half of it
just like that just like that is the
part you were missing you also barred he
borrowed liquids jacket
he's like yeah i like it this is liquids
it's kind of chilly
you defeated something naomi
i just had some kind of hallucination is
it from the nano machines
no that's from the edibles that i
slipped into your pasta earlier
[Laughter]
right next to your your cigarette also
stomach
smells is that from
is that from one of the like uh metro pr
bundles that they sent over
a while back here or daisy or something
like that
yeah yeah i knew it would come in handy
i held on to it for a reason
i was like one day this will be a bit
this will be useful
uh
we're supposed to go down here right now
isn't it
uh yeah
you gotta find the c4 and then do the
tappy tap with the walls
where the hell is the c4 it's in one of
these isn't it
yeah uh now be careful some of them are
booby trapped
oh yeah this this is
no boobies in this stream
burmese 100 true there it is
oh my god oh yeah whoa
crawl first motion mode
uh i know we're playing twin snakes we
made it
how do i get all of this wait you were
actually able to shoot and stuff
yeah well hold on this is
the dog version's got some wacky stuff
going on i don't know how to get out of
this
this is the feature right like this is
hello
hello
oh you got a double tap oh okay
that was wild oh i think they added that
to this version or maybe not
yeah this was not in the original
there's so much
i don't i'm not sure if i'd like that
so the one you have to blow open is bomb
left
west i believe over here
yeah finding this wall at first was also
a fun time yeah
especially on the crap tvs from back in
the day
also good luck because you have a
different controller i the last time i
replayed this
when i was using the different mappings
i had such a hard time like
sticking the things up the wall okay i
screwed that up
did i do it yeah
yeah nailed it first try
you'll find me you'll find me on awesome
games done quick next year
oh i nailed it i'm
pro just as spooky as hallways
i'm going to save that sounds a good
idea
this fight might be interesting on the
controller you're on
ah the menu did that save or not i have
no idea there was no confirmation
yes save uh
armory system underscore is that what
this area is called
it's creating a new file every time
i think that's it yeah i think i think
you're good
uh so
uh ben what is we're about to meet uh
the cowboy cowboy the cowboy
what is this first line
oh
handsome guy like you doing in a
basement like this
firstly jake jake's mustache incredible
it looks it looks accurate to the ps1
version of a mustache
it's perfect i love it look at old baker
here
just like stuffed turkey
that looks good over and over again is
yours
smaller than it should be yeah my cell
com looks like i'm holding up a hard
drive
yeah that's not
normal uh wait
what's going oh it doesn't have the
suppressor on it that's why
yeah but he still looks kind of small
even still it looks jacked up
yeah yeah so uh ben you went for the
line
what's the handsome guy like you doing
down in this basement let's see if
revolver asks a lot of says
that ah yes please i hope he says it
very confident about this one how are
you doing sexy
[Laughter]
it's me cowboy mcmahon if i remember i
thought it was so you're the one
is it so no that's that's not him that's
a lie
another boss tech president kenneth
baker right
i think it's i think do you remember
what is jake
um i think it's like one wrong move
and the old man blows or something like
that oh yeah
one wrong and he kablooey yes something
coolest thing ever by the way that
touch that why in the blue
sorry i got my my fan fiction cece
you're the one the boss
keeps talking about that's that's where
i was
leaving cliff
here to spin guns and string up old men
with bombs
jake you look a lot like mel get solid
for snake right now
i'm i'm no hero i need you to get on the
floor and do that very very sensual worm
like maneuver
[Laughter]
what is your favorite mid-battle quote
from revolver ocelot because i know mine
right off the top of my head
now i'll show you uh for me it's six
shots that's all the bullets i need to
kill you snake i love to reload
that's mine nothing beats the feeling of
sliding a long silver bullet into a
well-greased chamber
yep that oh i'll never i had to pause
when i heard that
it was too much i mean
is he wrong he's not wrong
where's my gun where is
of the sounds that kenneth baker makes
just over and over again
it's going to take me a few minutes to
get into the rhythm of this oh i need to
put away my left oh my god that bullet
is coming
it is either gonna graze my ass or
it's gonna miss completely i am not
gonna move place your bets now
is it gonna hit me or not i'm gonna call
miss i'm gonna believe
you're gonna say miss yeah i'm gonna no
i trust revolver he's gonna hit you
ah
i'm just barely not so good revolver
flipping toho grazing all the bullets
all the time
i'm alive again let's go
yeah he really keeps it paced with what
he has to say
uh i also just want to say shout out to
my favorite one of my favorite ocelot
deliveries in the entire series
is coming up one specific line that's
like stuck in your head for your entire
life
you got this yeah yeah this this it's in
the bag this is this is
weird the game is like really chugging
and i don't understand why this coke
yeah the pc version
dies yeah battle for some reason it's
there's a lot of stuff going on you know
all those wires are individually
rendered
yeah and the bullets are ricocheting and
yeah the physics that has to be pointed
to
look at him what a chump they'll be
trying to talk about the smell of your
own death just shoot him in the back
[Laughter]
oh my god i accidentally took it off
yo he's into the straight up shoot there
he's such a slippery he's such a
slippery old fella
he moves real fast for an old man yeah
he also moves real fast with his
allegiances in the plot throughout the
entire series
very it's very annoying who's he's like
triple undercover
got him in the loop they're pretty good
pretty good there it is
you're pretty good here it comes
we know the line oh my god let's do it
my hand my hand
his accent goes away my hand
the only time he's not playing cool guy
yeah he's like damn
the facade drops wow this pc version is
having a
we'll meet time you're lucky you cut my
whole hand
oh look the suppressor appeared
i have no name
this is a scene that went full
ridiculous in
snakes back flips and [ __ ] like that
he like kicks a rock at him like he cuts
the wall in half and kicks it at snake
yeah this is me every time i have to go
into a meeting
i feel monday's got me like yeah
oh my god this pc version at gog
any optimization in there pals can you
talk
no one cares what you think baker he
goes hell yeah i can talk now let me
tell you all about about
race military industrial complex
do you have 45 minutes
this game does a lot of the um remember
from kung pao
when they go i only did this uh
that doesn't mean that i'm dead yet
well we got some some uh donations
really quick
that i think i should read let's do it
uh from zach gunnell we got
fifty dollars that just says snake yeah
shout out to zach yeah shout out to zach
no one asks for uh no one's asked for a
bad um uh
bad cameo yet not yet uh people just
love yelling snake yeah but i feel like
just gonna give them that
whenever i can you know good okay
but yeah thomas gave twenty five dollars
uh showing uh
support from the bcvg server
nice that that twenty-five points thank
you
uh and elder gave
a hundred dollars with no note no
comment just a hundred dollars
in all of our thanks for you oh shout
out to elder shut up
elders one of our discord mods he's he's
awesome he's he's a champ
thanks thank you remember folks
i'll go on oh just one more amal gave
ten dollars
thank you so much we are raising money
for ablegamers
um oh which does a lot of work
uh in making gaming accessible for
people with disabilities
oh god just crawl you guys
right it's crawling is this is this is
this the straight one
you saw cigarettes dude yeah i do have
cigarettes
yeah the angled one is the one that gets
me
yes uh yeah so we're raising money for
ablegamers
our goal is thirty thousand dollars
which we're hoping to do in a week it's
a tall order
so um even we know it's a tall order but
we were like let's shoot for the moon
and like see what we can do um
so please do not donate generously if
you can if you can't
you know you got some you know you've
got some rich friends you know some
whales just hit them up and be like
listen
maybe you don't need to buy another
ferrari this month
just give some of that money over here
you know and uh
we'll do metal gear quotes yeah and
we'll do metal gear clothes
i actually i got to see ablegamers in
action a couple of years ago
uh steve and craig and the crew invited
me
uh for them to do a setup at a hospital
and it was just really cool to see them
go in there and kind of like swoop in
and basically this hospital gave them a
spare room they cleared out the spare
room
and uh they set it up with computers uh
and and just all the
every computer and every station every
console had all different types of tech
for folks with different disabilities
and uh they
train the staff they show the staff how
to use everything
and then they just let people in if
they're residents at the hospital
or treatment center they come in and
everyone's immediately like
yeah video games and it's it's the
coolest thing ever to see in action like
their work is really really vital
yeah and like it's important to consider
that
they do like i said earlier they do a
lot of educational stuff where they help
people who want to design
games understand things a bit better
from people
from the perspective of people who you
know are have disabilities and
when you expose people to to those
opportunities and you create interest in
games and development of games what
you're doing is just guaranteeing that
in the future these people are
in a position where they can make games
that are accessible and we don't have to
go through
you know this kind of uphill struggle of
making it
making people understand it because
those are the people that will be
creating the games at the same time
and the the ablegamers like educational
efforts are
super vital as well so every every
amount that you can uh donate is
incredibly useful
so please do worth it it's like direct
happiness funding
yeah exactly direct happiness funding is
a good way to look at it uh where the
hell are we going now i can't remember
uh i think you need to call her oh
you're gonna get a sneak up on this guy
first though
give him give him the old chokey choke
yeah yeah yeah
give him the old dead
yeah yeah hey we did it we did one
and we got the suppressor it's all
coming together
jake do you remember the frequency for
mero
it's my wifi password one full oh my god
wait no 141.15
let's see if he's right
140.15 sorry oh
fake metal gear fan there he is i know i
mean i didn't i didn't do it myself
because i cannot remember
i'm so bad with number retention in my
mind
i would have had to run to my local game
store again
i would be honest of all the things that
i like love and
remember metal gear i'm not good with
codex yeah
i keep this one as my wi-fi password and
then when people ask for it they're like
what
why does it have a period in it like why
don't you have a dot
you just you gotta you just hand them a
copy of metal gear don't say anything
yeah figure it out this is the guest
wi-fi guest wi-fi only figure it out
i don't need lectures you're just like
your uncle you know
how do you know my uncle we go way back
what's your uncle constantly telling me
how to press the button to move here
your uncle told me you have to go up
letters and down letters
[Laughter]
a wise man
extensive knowledge of the action
uh you're next on this one are you ready
okay
i'm i'm ready look away yes
i'm ready snake says mero's eyes
are a certain way she says are they
rookie's eyes and then he says no and
then he describes them
how does he describe meryl's eyes and uh
we have jake dressed as meryl to give
you extra
kind of motivation so if you want to be
inspired look into jake's eyes
how would you describe those it's the
exact same eyes that merrell has and the
exact same
impulses stirred within snake and
those are the most beautiful and
compassionate eyes i've ever seen
you are a hundred percent correct
yeah i'm stuck in for some reason oh i
don't know why beautiful compassionate
uh just stuck but just like jake with
such conviction
yeah just like jake merrill has
beautiful and compassionate eyes
he'd love to see it indeed
oh god damn she talks a lot though
there's a lot of
exposition you gotta do you know uh
catching her up on all the heart attacks
yeah this is just he's just like he's
flowing he's just floating here
she goes anyway i'm gonna open the thing
go through it look out for the lasers
yeah watch out for the lasers bro
i think you have to hang around for a
little bit yeah do i have the
did i get the goggles
oh the thermal uh no i don't think you
got them
what did i pick up here then oh
suppressor this espresso
you slap that thing on there too yeah
you have to manually equip that
if i remember what where
is it unless you just oh no i did it
automatically
um where are the goggles they're in one
of the building uh
one of the armory things right they're
downstairs
they're either it's the thermal and the
night vision goggles i get mixed up i
thought they were
back in this room but uh i could be very
no i think you're right i think they're
upstairs here like upstairs
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh where the
action button was first
yeah what yeah will your life change for
the better forever
action button first yeah
oh nothing some weird kink
that mask yeah you know
we're at four hundred dollars already
wow
that's a great start that is a hell of a
start thank you so much everyone
i forgot about him
[Laughter]
it's gonna keep you on your toes a
little bit
you don't want to just do it the
old-fashioned way and try and wing it
with the cigarettes where it's near
impossible
uh i'll try it but let me let me grab
the uh
dude you can do this whole thing in
first person now and just sidestep that
stuff can't you oh
that makes it way easier holy hell get
out of here forget about this i'm
i'm out this version is cheating
that's easy mode no i won't do it i
won't do it
i'm going to do it the old way wait is
it
is it over there i think i think oh no
because
that's a maybe that's a level four room
what's the other room let's have a look
from
over here oh my god
[Music]
that's level two room it's gotta be that
one it's gotta be
i just need to get
can you just like no scope that guy i
guess i could with my uh
first person mode but i'm gonna i'm
gonna give him the
the art of choke
no i don't even have to choke him i can
just sneak in and out
easy clap i know you were here that's a
mind detector which is
ah the mind d a thing you think is
really important and then you learn you
can just crawl the whole way
yeah wait did it fine did we not get the
where the hell is it then
it's not here it's not here that means
it's gotta be in the basement
is anyone in chat aware
uh if anyone remembers where these
goggles are
let us know i think it's in the basement
uh it's in the tank hanger the small
room with the camera
someone's saying oh
i said who's that action partner save me
click that action button yeah
in the tank hanger so all the way
outside then uh that might depend
on if you can because i know you can get
them before
the revolver battle yeah i don't
remember what it's like to get them
after
i don't know where you go
all right we'll see someone's just
someone's watching and just screaming
like it's right there
is people staying in the room next to
the hello for it
yeah i figured it was in the heliport
can you the [ __ ]
i mean could you could could try to do
the cigarette thing
oh yikes
we got the cardboard box no
action button time again
actually fun save me
they're like the gods are like well he
pressed the action button there's not
much more we can do about it
hey you're doing you you're doing what
you learned yeah they taught you
in training i'm telling you playing on a
playing xbox controller is real weird
i believe it yeah i've never touched any
of them on
on xbox like even the ports it's very
very strange
like it's wild how much muscle memory
you build up with a specific version of
a controller
like the reason i got caught there is
because i forgot what button it was to
bring up
the menu to select to the level two card
there's also a lot of like pressure
sensitive button things you don't get
with uh
with the xbox controller which is really
sad
yeah yeah
i'll be right back someone's at my door
right oh it's
a genome soldier oh no
found him did he leave
oh no
actually know the difference hey twin
snakes is a is
a heck of a thing i actually think i
played twin sticks more than i probably
should have
yeah most people
have probably played twin snakes more
than they should have
oh i'm on the screen twice now
i'm gonna say just what we need no one
needs that
no one needs that
snake like shakespeare said
i was gonna i was gonna i was gonna do
you there and get you to
recite me
i thought about it i thought about it
for a second
i i would have absolutely had to
improvise
this guy this guy this one guy
[Music]
i don't think you could test that no you
can't i was hoping to just hide
yeah now now another dude has to get is
his neck broken
what relax
welcome to the elevator of death
nobody leaves my genome soldiers come
but never leave
perfect nail it kill that
jumps onto a missile from a hindi yeah
there are a lot there are a lot of
there's a lot of octane moments
like that i'm trying to think my
favorite
my favorite twin snakes over done scene
uh that hindi missile kick is a good one
also the the back flip uh when he gets
shot at by sniper wolf
or he like he backflips away from the
shot
and then lands on his sniper rifle and
kicks it up into the air and then
catches it
yeah just saw him about that that i'm
like okay
what if snake actually did that
i'm in uh jake are you back shout out to
the shout out to the fedex guy that's
why i had to get up
oh okay my headband off because i didn't
want to answer the door like a weirdo
the fedex guy actually said to consider
donating to ablegamers
oh yeah it's good because yeah it's it's
it's a good cause he told me all about
it he said it's great uh
for education in disability in the
gaming sphere
in terms of uh both implementation and
technology so uh yeah
wow ready to consider it all right
really nice guy i love this fedex guy
he's awesome
is your camera on you're just showing up
as your discord icon on my screen
the camera is back on i can see him yeah
i'm on you must cross the river before
you tell the crocodile
can the stream see see uh jake's camera
or is it just me that can just see
his beautiful icon face use your brain
to avoid traps and stay away from the
enemy that looks like i
am looks like a discord i blew it
oh well while we get that sword i can
okay
donation things i've saved it so here's
the thing with the uh
metal gear solid pc version there's a
distinct chance that when i tab out of
this to fix
jake's camera it's all gonna crash so uh
pray pray for us pray for us it was all
wonderfully held together somehow
in paper clips
see we've got uh there's all three
really quick donations i can do i guess
okay cool i'll figure this out while
that happens
we got lord solar with 20 saying huh
what was that noise
oh classic that's the noises of you
making a wonderful donation to help
wonderful people
hell yeah that was the noise that was
the noise
uh we got siren uh giving 25
saying love the stream shout outs to the
uh gamespot after dark and because video
games podcasts
oh yeah yeah you love to hear it
and uh sal from qatar says uh videos
video games can help people everywhere
and dropped a hundred dollars
wow thank you that's amazing thank you
style
i appreciate that appreciate you and
everyone else who's been giving
uh whatever they can and remember if if
you're kind of stored on cash share it
around let other people know
that's just as good as giving
yeah please do
okay i think i fixed jake there now i
need to fix
ben i think maybe maybe
you've been trying to do that for years
savage
uh the only thing i don't have is a
ninja
attire for cyborg ninja you hate to see
it
i have i have a mass effect n7 helmet i
was thinking about just wearing that
instead i might have to do that
sounds a pretty good call
all right so we're we're good on on this
end still it seems
so that's good so
okay so i need to
do this nope that was too much
a lot of love for your your bloodborne
wallpaper which is definitely very rad
it is super dope thank you
thank you so much it's like it's got
everywhere i think it's missing like
one weapon i think um
but i'm not sure exactly which one
okay that's that
now please don't break
well the the fedex driver did give us
some good advice
so yes that's true all right we're going
to do this the old way
i've saved it yeah you got you got to
save so that's what matters
i'm going to save it again place your
bets how many attempts does this take me
i believe you're gonna do it in one one
yeah
what's chat saying i believe in your job
uh and you're not using you're not using
the new first person mode right no this
is gonna be a
a classic cigarette um
cigarette run classic oh my god did you
see that you're at pirouette
this is not how this was intended to
work
oh it's so it's so rough the xbox
controller is absolutely doing me right
now
but you you look at how look at how far
you are you've wow
you got it wow let's go
can we ban that person please
you made it look easy i remember as a
kid like my my heart
pounded yeah
i definitely like did one than like side
viewed and
there's a lot
save again please
we're gonna we're gonna chat to our good
friend
be careful ah mr
deep throat there are claymore mines
around there
jake look away from the screen
uh when uh snake says
who are you the mysterious
person says their name can you remember
the line
um is it
you can call me dot dot
that is disgusting jake please that's
not
hey it's the game that is absolutely
filthy everyone saw that clip that out
jake talking dirty on on stream no
you are correct where the hell are these
mines
that's a good question remind e i liked
the
version i narrowly threaded myself
between every single one of these
i have no idea you might be asking why
do you need to collect these mines well
one so that you don't blow your ass up
too because there's a certain stairway
seen later on where it becomes very
useful
oh yeah
all right this is the that is the weird
the shadow behind the
text yeah it's this this version's a
little it's a little wacky in it
a little rough all right so this is the
boss i struggle most with
um ordinarily and i'm hard because of
the way you aim
yeah yeah and i i can't imagine how
annoying this is gonna be
with this controller
ben first line what does he say quick oh
shoot uh this is
it it's not snakes don't belong in
alaska but that's the only thing that's
come in my mind
this is the ravens territory snakes do
not belong
in alaska
[Music]
snakes don't take the second yeah you
got it
you got it you got it i have nothing for
uh vulcan raven unfortunately
oh i love vulcan raven i like his life
dang that was like spot on there is i
love that anime dive
too that's sick landing right you belong
on the ground
just like the snake oh
yeah what was the eagle raptor one uh
the eagle raptor one
cryptic metaphor yeah
come let's fight i'm gonna get blown up
here yeah first he lifts his he lets his
dope in the in the like the genome
soldiers sit
on top you blow him up poor guy
we got a chump
no like anywhere near the hitbox you
just get like knocked out yeah you just
get like
nice that's a slam dunk that was like
see how you're like see are you like
this
the old artifact he's so stoked
yeah this is all he's been able he's
been waiting to do this at this nuclear
waste disposal facility he's like one
night
yeah when i get my chance to shine i'm
gonna say see are you like this
turd guy ready to roll let's go erica
number two becomes burnt toast very
quickly
you didn't even need to use chaff
grenades
jake do you remember what raven says
here when he's talking to uh
ocelot um
[Laughter]
all i know is that the tank's all blown
up and you don't even see him he's just
inside
he just left i don't think he knows i'm
still in here
i hope you are happy he got the card
a little longer oh it's liquidy
no less because that's why a demon just
threw four grenades at us
he fights like a demon he underhands
grenades
into us like a demon you did run
you can see the seams of the jpeg
the greatest game of all time one of the
greatest games of all time
it is again in battle same prediction
as always yes a raven on my head
for his blood also it's like low-key
magic doesn't it like
it come out it shoots out yeah it like
he shoots out second paddle
it's like cold gears all right question
for you guys
yes what where you just got more health
yes what do you think snake is doing i
always thought he was wiping the blood
off of his mouth
in a cool way and he's getting more
health but was he eating something
no i thought i thought i always just
thought like he was like stretching his
neck
so i thought he was eating a ration but
he never eats the rations in your
inventory like he has like an extra yeah
he's got a secret gallery or something
yeah
he was inedible he's eating that edible
yeah it's like he's just talking
someone's
gotta keep going it also kind of looks
like he's like talking to someone
like someone on the other side is like
yeah you can have more health now
and he's like sick dude he's like thank
you copy that
it's reading a secret note he wrote to
himself you are cool
it's like thanks pass snake i appreciate
it
i like this room this room this room
yeah yeah it gives me so much anxiety
you absolutely
can't use your guns sorry i absolutely
can't
put a thing in there which one of you
remembers
the codec number for nastasha romanenko
[Music]
i can't remember what i'm saying
oh ben hold on
i forgot to i forgot to do something
there we go there we go
i fixed it on a limited budget
no one remembers nastasha romanenkos
well ladies and gentlemen it is
i i don't know i just took a guess uh
the least called character
she uh she gives you like a massage and
stuff it's nice
through the controller maybe she's the
person that he's talking to
or maybe to get more health
why what is that
why are they just moving back and forth
i've not seen that before
it's the gut it's the gog feature man
he's
they definitely are supposed to be up
and around things
is the guy upstairs broken too
he looks like he's moving around
how are you supposed to get up there if
he's like maybe patrolling maybe if
you're gonna have to knock
kill he'll break from his his stuck loop
what how did he see you see i always go
left that was a knock
ah what
what the hell they can't see up
we're just gonna have to load game
that's fine
what is going on with the enemy loops in
this
i'm very disappointed in everyone uh
hold on the the actual overlay was
broken for a couple of minutes
since since uh yeah and no one in slack
told me
oh hate to see that
you absolutely must really do
[Music]
meanwhile i'm like sweating buckets here
oh but you're you're killing it dude is
this is this loop normal
it just doesn't feel normal i could
never look at this guy because i always
hook left whenever i come in this room
all the time oh you go up that way
i never go up that way i always go up
that way
i'm gonna go up this way but this is
highly unorthodox it's something
away but it's also just like faster
oh as long as you don't screw it up
just like that she's barely barely right
be like there's no person in that dark
corner
damn it who is that snake
snake it's scattered
i called you by accident colonel don't
give me that [ __ ]
what do you do when someone calls you in
that situation like don't breathe dude
just hope it ends i guess
nick press the action button to hold
your breath
be careful shut up
yeah the fact that naomi was like don't
worry i already programmed his nano
machine so he can't use his gun
what does that is that like what is that
all about
she's like i've i've figured out how to
use nano machines to eliminate
free will like what you did what get rid
of your tree
to freeze your trigger finger i undid
years of training in an instant
like how dude
you didn't get that whole video i don't
like this i don't like this
ben you're a crazy person i'm going my
way
if that was a modern game there would
have been that slight window where
he saw you but you took him out yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but this is the good old days damn it
i just realized you can press start to
just skip conversations entirely i did
not know you could do that previously
so is there a window where i can sneak
by
we tap on the complete opposite other
side of the truck so he has to walk all
the way around
and then just go the opposite direction
yeah
should be like ah what was that noise
and you'll already be upstairs by the
time okay so he doesn't
he doesn't turn all the way around so
once he moves over to the right i'm good
to just jump in here
yeah
yeah
bait that boy and you're
gonna go home he's any wiser yeah yeah
he needs to retire
that was embarrassing
that's embarrassing for him age hasn't
slowed you down one bit
yeah but he failed guard school and uh
he's definitely like yeah
all right this guy comes older you guard
the nuke room
you know it's not anything too serious
it shouldn't be too difficult it was
just phillips
here's a gun that you can't use
this guy he's real proud that he's
he's very pleased with himself in it
i i gotta say i really appreciate that
your playstyle is
like actually waiting and sneaking
because
yeah i'd been on that guy breaking his
neck like you said no dude
no i i am i'm a pure self player
apart from apart from the three times
where i activate and learn
uh choking death on a yeah
time for some voyeurism
it uh it'd be like that sometimes
sometimes sometimes you gotta
figure out who your ally is by staring
at their ass
it's very important kojima thinks
is it is it this dog god is this the god
nah
i don't think so nah ain't you
oh is it no it's not oh
god damn just like that guy had a potato
body
yeah we're looking for
a little more swagger than that lad had
it's really funny that this many guards
are in charge of the cubicle room
yeah no
oh god what have i done you're stealth
now
oh slick
is it that one i couldn't see
oh no it's not time possibly
for people who don't know what we're
doing here this must look mad in it
so allow me to explain it yeah jake hit
him with the knowledge
so what you're trying to do here is find
merrell merrill
silverberg niece of colonel campbell is
currently
disguised as a guard now earlier
snake identified merrell uh because of
her
uh alluring uh
backside backside her walk style uh the
sway over hips
her unique gate so to speak so now that
they have to meet up the only way that
he can signal to her like hey
it's me is you have to find which guard
it is
by identifying them how he previously
saw her and that is by her walk
it all makes sense it's
gaming you wouldn't understand it can't
it's not that one
we're gonna remember she does go to the
bathroom yeah you
like i wonder if it's the one that's in
here she might already be
does she go in the bathroom on her own
or do you have to kind of like get to
her
i don't remember i think you have to get
uh hard i used to always get nervous
that looks like a dude that's not it
that's not it yeah that means it's the
other one then
is there only two though i think so
maybe that's not it
oh i think that might be her nope that's
not
she turned away
okay what we're gonna do is we're just
gonna
start taking god's out of the equation
i don't think this is merrell
if that is merrell she did
yeah sorry lady
i didn't realize you can you can sell
off the uh
okay this should make things easier
oh my god it's not her that's not her
either
oh wait are we at that point yeah did
you see that she ran away
yeah oh you're giving her the time
no she's the other guard spotted me and
it was her
[Music]
what what what what is going on
are we supposed to do the stuff with the
cyborg ninja before we meet her
because we got the we got the nikita
launcher
oh maybe
i don't think so are we ahead of our are
we ahead of ourselves maybe we're like
ahead of ourselves
it's hard when you're like half paying
attention to the dialogue yeah yeah
yeah you just
give colonel campbell a call see what
gets up with him
no what can i do for you mailings is fun
to call too
good luck snake get out of here
second floor basement baby that's the
one
all right well then that means i don't
it means merrell time is off
i would like to apologize to everyone to
waste for wasting their time
we thought we stared at a lot of genome
soldier asses
for no reason whatsoever
sometimes you go
it happens yeah
uh
there i'll just check checking
it's all good all right let's see
if we can do the uh nikita in one
can you one shot one kill one shot one
kill
let's save it first while you're saving
i'm gonna do a really quick donation
read because this one's very important
okay uh from amanda baldino
oh a hundred dollars oh
thank you that's my wife
it's nice donation i told her to do it
anonymously shout out to her
oh thank you so much
i'm getting all red all flushed oh
it's cause you're excited we're about to
do this in one
yes this is this is something that
no gamer has ever achieved this feat
the first time live this is our first
time live gamer for the first time live
on a gamespot stream
thanks dude cheers bro
the problem we have is that we don't
have a ration mr dave
throat
that was a practice run yeah it's
because i i i didn't go for the uh
the full boost this is the this is the
real play
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's go just like that easy easy peasy
now we can get to the good stuff no let
me up
i don't have any russians
yeah you're you're living on the edge
i don't know can you open any of these
doors yeah somebody's [ __ ] off yeah
there we go
ah there we go yeah
oh look at that look at the ranger nut
buddy
here we go here we go
let's go let's go it's very good uh
and who is this
what is cyborg ninja's first line
oh these first line ones throw me for a
loop
yeah yeah
you've got um you've got snake
for the first time uh
the cyborg ninja gray fox frankie yeager
uh you're stalling here you're stalling
here get on with it
uh what's uh
what's it bandana
man like you doing in a hallway like
this
let's see i think in the lineage you
have a dance for the devil in a painted
moonlight
there it is jakey jake you wanna
spiderman
oh you say okay we've got sweet
spiderman okay
oh pizza time cut by some type of blade
god
oh that sounds scariest music yeah
fashion building incredible
yeah it's like this is
what's what mission is it in uh metal
gear solid five where you have to
basically kill off your entire team yeah
that's this yeah for my my
bad quote i do have a cool bit of uh
trivia for the sounds that
uh happen right now in the background
let's hear it yeah
they're like uh i'm trying to remember
exactly what it is but they are
all of the stops that kojima would take
uh on
public transport to work but like
they're they're said in reverse or
something yeah
there's there's some weird trick to it
but they're they're all the stops on the
subway or whatever the train that you
would have to go past
i'm trying to remember what the actual
quote is i think it is something to do
well it's not i think it's about names
neither enemy nor friend it could be
that
yeah or or it's uh or he doesn't say
anything about icon
yeah oh it's like he just makes him
peepee yeah
[Music]
yeah i think it's neither enemy nor
friend
okay
stealth camouflage who are you neither
oh it's where is my friend
ah snake
you're that ninja you're a
that was the line where i was like i
love you i love you
are you gonna give him a real fight are
you gonna you're gonna cheese it
what do you want hmm
i'll give him a real fight i like giving
him the real fight i feel like he
deserves
give him what he wants yeah hurt me more
that is uh acceptable uh gray fox helmet
that's the best i need like tokugawa
like i need to have it yeah yeah that'd
be good
yeah heavy industries
make me feel alive again
get punched
of all combat only a fool trusts his
life to a weapon
that's true this guy doesn't know
my fists are certified weapons
[Laughter]
hey
uh this level two has all like for the
time
some pretty incredible destruction all
the glasses breakable
all the computer screens break
i would play it and i would just throw
grenades everywhere
just to see all the damage and the
papers fly around and stuff
a luci is saying that uh you're gonna
have some trouble with the the pc
mapping this is where she
she stopped yeah it is it's currently
now i'm a gamer i'll figure it out you
got you got this i
remember punch punch kick yeah it's all
in the mind
also playing as him in vr missions was
really cool
yeah incredibly underutilized stop
kicking me
one mode you nerd
all right we gotta play we gotta play
conservative now i'm out of
i'm russians
now i'm not going to play dirty i'm
going to give him hand to hand because
he deserves that much
i'm just going to do the old hit hit and
run
yeah yeah
wow grow up oh got out of there
oh sometimes you just gotta take a
window sometimes you can just go kick a
filing cabinet and a window in
take out your anger
oh jeez it's that that kick is the one
that gets me
it's the the whisper kick yeah
can't even do it
[Applause]
oh no it's just out of range
so you got to give them the the warning
blows you know yeah
it's snake i'm gonna punch this out just
watch this it's really cool
it's not gonna punch you through this
wow
get closer i'm ready quit chasing me
i'm trying to get him to kick this chair
he just will not do it
kick the chair bro you've got the pace
oh those papers though
incredible yeah you got the chair yeah
some office workers gonna have a rough
time he's destroying this
office workers entire ship this is like
frostbite engine this is
someone it's gonna pant it like someone
in hr just being like oh my lord
what is going on in there that ninja's
back and he's destroying all of our
equipment
[Laughter]
what's he doing he's just like he's like
really he's like i want to fight a solid
snake it's like bro you need to fight a
pile of papers first before you come for
me
people in the chat are suggesting to use
chaff grenades but we're doing it
no we're not going to do that no weapons
as requested
by mr frankie frankie yeah he was like
fight me
he's like knives only
one v one me he said me me at the center
of the map knives only
so we're giving him what he wants
i love the sound that it makes when you
when he kicks like one of these filing
cabinets is the same as someone getting
punched in the face
[Applause]
yeah oh this is a fun one he gets to
play a little bit of hide and seek
i don't have any rations
one punch and i'm done
[Applause]
i know there's a way to like bait him
into punching you as well
but like if i
wow he ran up on me there ain't for you
he won't
get into your fist
he did it again get away from me and you
got
do i get it dude
all right all right all right i forgot i
forgot
about that punch i've got his number now
though
time to give him the gun time to give
him the business
now i'm gonna do i'm gonna do hand to
hand only daryn square i respect yeah
frank frank deserves that he's been
through a lot it's true
[Applause]
but i'm really gonna give it to him i'm
gonna go aggressive i'm gonna go
aggressive and see what happens
it's true let's get the rations on
[Applause]
while you're while you're doing some
punches really quick got some some more
cool hot uh donations to read
yeah uh oh god one from
one you may have heard of them bake
baked
jaldino oh wow for one
uh 139 dollars and 44 cents
saying loving the stream guys oh thank
you jake who could who could that be
i mean currently we've only got a snake
on on stream so
yeah uh and then another one from
snake uh for fifty dollars what
what yo he's got he wouldn't
he likes you teleport through
all right he's he's like he's not
playing yeah he's walking he's warping
my ass now
he got real mad after i like baited him
into the
ah it happened again
why is this game really struggling with
the optic camo you guys gonna say
anytime
yeah and also like it struggles with his
like uh
his uh the light on his helmet he's
running up on me again
he's like i'm gonna play with him
actually i'm gonna run up on you
yeah i think he knows how hide and seek
works
what what was that you don't learn about
what hide and seek is when you grow up
on the battlefield
am i right true
get out of here i'm out of rations again
oh no i do i do respect you not
resorting to the chapter
oh yeah the flipping card
no weapon run here and he's gonna do it
i will do it i will do it
i will do it all right this one this one
goes out to chat this one goes that chat
make chat make sure you donate this
one's for you
third time's a charm
i am gonna punch you in the gob
frank your time is
coming we're breaking that glass right
off the bat
let's get this get
[Laughter]
come here bro
[Applause]
come to the computer lab if you want an
ass kicking
i have no commentary i'm like oh [ __ ]
can we just do spin kicks on my body
imagine fighting a metal ninja man and
kicking his metal body like right in
right in the leg like and enough to
to like actually make him be like ah it
hurts exactly how yeah
you're like bro
can you take your kinks elsewhere please
not shaming you but you know yeah we're
just trying to do some missions here
we're trying to save the world or
whatever
a time and place
oh you're you're done man you're washed
i downloaded you
[Applause]
i know this is the one yeah i'm not
jinxing it i'm saying it with confidence
i feel it
that's good
this is this is where it usually falls
apart so let's see if we can
keep it together as long as he doesn't
keep doing that jump
where he jumps up and he looks like dave
matthews band logo
i did it again it's because his uh his
camo
like slows down my computer this pc
version man
get out of there perfect perfect
he like walked up to you and turned it
off he's like hey
we've already got that that server rack
ration i can hear him kicking
i can hear the sounds of kicking coming
from the distance
all right i know how to do this
what you do is you bait him with one
punch
yeah and he does that and you go
get out of here idiot you got computer
brain
to figure this out what did my computer
your parents think i was playing when i
was playing this
yeah just remember everybody this is a
no item no weapon fight
this is a fair fight this is he's doing
it completely dry
never been done before the juke this is
the first time
this is this is world record ever yeah
no one's ever done this
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a muhammad ali level dodge wait
can you actually like punch him first
don't actually do it let me try i don't
know no tries
not right i want to live this beat down
i want to i want to be there for it
oh it is an angle oh my god he's dueling
the first person
let's go
get out of here the cyborg ninjas
incredible
incredible now just look out for that
we're almost there
what are you even supposed to do in this
bit you just avoid him yeah you just
avoid him right yeah
yeah all i'm saying is
i'm just gonna put a claymore mine down
here it's got nothing to do with him if
he appears there that's his own fault
this is an extra yeah it's still a no
it's a no weapons run
that was nothing to do with him
he's really about that chair yeah that
chairs oh he's stuck in the same spot
yeah that shows like i wasn't meant to
be used like this
this version man
i i only did it to get him out yeah
that's fair
it had to be bro where's my claim on my
mind are you technically beaten
where's my clan moment
that's a good question did it glitch out
like everything else's version does
[Music]
where's he gone
we did it yeah we did it
do you remember me come on
can't be let's go uh ben
was it ben is it uh jake's turn i think
it might be jake's turn actually yeah
when uh snake opens up the uh kodak
what's the first thing he says
not again uh oh boy
um
it's i think it's to naomi
and he's like was that gray fox
i don't know i don't have a good one oh
no
bendy remember i'm pretty sure it's the
revelation that he's like hey yo that
was gray fox
yeah i think yeah something like that if
i remember his colonel
he's like great fox colonel
that ninjas great fox
you're telling me that robot man is a
great box i was like a robot man dude
and i look like a fox
snake are you okay did you shoot are you
are you sad like no means just like we
have you on the radar none of that what
are you talking about
you've been sitting on the toilet for
like an hour right now
no doubt there it is no doubt about it
like the amount the amount of things her
character goes through in this game oh
yeah
are you one of them incredible hell of
an arc yeah
for someone that never really actually
appears on screen alone
here we go captain pea pants come on
love
his first question is are you in a taco
yeah
incredible just it's like
when you're all about that life you are
all about that
gear life i want to ask you something i
want to ask you something
you said i want to ask you something a
rail gun you said
yeah oh wait this is an otakon scene
only standard nuclear missiles than they
should all this is the like
this is look at the way snake is sitting
legs crossed
it's like very weird it's very weird
he's he's distinguished he's
distinguished he's sitting fancy
ran on that's why they're all red long
forgotten
you see this this these servers run
google stadia
they haven't been used in years damn
damn i'm such a fool
i pre-ordered in everything i was so
ready snake
i was a premium member snake they had
destiny they had crosstalk
but the one that wound up getting used
was me
using sounds to help mankind it's just
in the middle what do you guys like
better huey or
how underground i prefer huey because
he's
here he's like not pathetic he's just
like bumbling
the override system yeah archon is like
genuinely pathetic
and in five everything in five is his
fault they torture him like six times
i love the the part where he gets kicked
off of the thing
i just need and then like just glasses
out to kojima's and everyone's like ah
it's kojima saying that he got kicked
out of konami just like
he got kicked off a mother base
if you get a chance try to escape when
the coast is clear
like if i was archon i would let snake
leave before i
left so he doesn't have to watch me walk
with my pants covered in piss
[Laughter]
i'd be like you go first you go first
i'll me i'll
i'll be all right i'll be all right
instead of hobbling away with piss
like squelching in my underwear
just like your japanese animals he's
like yeah you're invisible but you still
smell like piss
everyone can tell your hair bad leg at
all
it's like hey snake later on i'll try to
give you one but then someone else takes
it yeah i could have just given it to
you right now when it would have been
much easier
but no that's the scene in that
elevator's legit jump scare i still
oh it's it's incredible yeah
it's the way the the zoom happens
yeah japan was the oh my god kojima
please
so many cutscenes see what is he doing
he's he's just he's like he did put it
on his mouth yeah
he did put it on his mouth that's
interesting he's applying burst
i like burt's bees chapstick but he
might be doing one of those really
intense like you know the the face palms
where you like
pull out your face downwards to be like
oh my god i hate all of this he could be
doing one of those that's how he gets
more health
yeah he goes oh he's like oh god
i need to get into my reserves i can't
believe i just fought this ninja at an
audience
i punched him to death i punched him in
just to death
i just got done fighting a tank and now
i punched a ninja to death what is
happening
almost destroyed the google stadium
service
and then he still has to fight a uh a
haunted man a helicopter
a brother um a big a big man
big gatling gunman big gardening gun man
and then a big robot
his day is nowhere near done yeah
our day is almost done though it's true
unfortunately yeah wow wow jeez i didn't
even realize that yeah time
flies when you're having fun metal gear
with your friends yeah
uh ben what are we at with the
donations where we at and have we got
any more recent ones
uh we have one more recent one from
another person you may recognize
uh good old alessandro barbosa hey
fifty dollars and said loving stream uh
let me
extend my my window here so i can read
the rest of it living stream
the only metal gear solid game i haven't
played through myself
work this evening thank you for the
entertainment thank you for watching
alessandra
what's up what's up
total is currently at 8.50 looks like
oh wow damn it's not bad that's amazing
for the for the opening stream i'm i'm
in let's see if we can real quickly look
at merrell's booty
we got we have to do one thing we tried
we're not going to get to liquid but i
have a liquid snake wig too oh
no yeah we miss it
all right i know exactly who it is
it's that one right there
that is way more
pronounced than i remember it that one
no not that one
nope they crossed over at some point and
i lost track of them
it's this one over here yeah yeah
i just want to i just want to see the uh
i want to see this
physio are you going to go physio mantis
psychomantis cutscene we get that that's
that special version of the cut scene if
we go quickly
don't move
and i think we might have gotten it
nobody look if you definitely got
it nobody look no oh we did oh we didn't
we went quick enough
we keep it
yeah in the wrong time okay let's do
let's just get to the part of the stream
where is mel get started play through
gun sexual
follow me i mean that's where we're at
now
are we are you gonna make us guess the
psycho mantis lines that's you horrible
horrible man
no uh ben you're ready okay
oh no when uh merrell is under
spell what does she say to snake
uh you're a wonderful gentleman and i
like you very much and i'd like to go on
a dinner date with you
oh ben you're close but it's a little
more sensual than that
i like this part she says mr foxhound
yeah she calls it mr foxhound i think
that's
really cool says snake let's go back to
my place and watch digimon the movie
and then if we have a good time you can
give me a little kiss on the cheek
and we'll see where this goes snake show
me your crypto portfolio
fine yo you're not
fine okay the fact that she gets the gas
masks effect to her
yeah it's so weird yeah
it's a lot of
the commander is waiting
all right we'll do this cut scene and
then we'll wrap it up
yeah let's guess uh we can guess
colonel's line
go for it jake when he uh uh
he says snake don't use your weapon
you're you're gonna have to punch her
yeah we're gonna have to please kick her
please
punch snake i need you to punch my niece
as much as you can
the only way snake i need you to beat
the [ __ ] out of my niece
this is what she mentioned since the
jordan pizza in the movie
and yeah uh yeah whoa
relax whoa
honestly i too wouldn't yeah i would say
the exact same thing
i would say the same thing if i was
confronted
don't use your weapon please use your
fists which you use
literally used to be up a robot ninja
minutes ago
use those same use that same force on my
fragile human daughter
[Laughter]
no worries that kick sent her across the
room
uh i i'm a bigger fan of using the the
stun grenades
myself i know we have
tam being just a complete brutal i'm i'm
i told you i was going to do it around
the little melee room i've done it all
melee running
huh i hope that's not your only trick
oh little snake no he's got at least two
more yeah
including crushing this version of the
game
[Music]
you've only finished half of your battle
pass in fortnite
i see you've created an only fans
account what no
no no no no no stop stop
psychologist please no
the the twin snakes version when he's
like oh it seems like you really
super smash brothers incredible all
right ladies and gentlemen that is the
end of our stream
i want to thank our guests uh ben and
jake for devoting
some time to hang out with us and play
metal gear thank you so much jake for
hanging out
thank you so much for coming with props
thanks for running this this was like
this was a blast it's good fun we should
do it again remember we are raising
money in aid of ablegamers
we are we've got a week of streams twice
a day the next one is going to feature
super eye patch wolf an h bomber guy two
of the smartest coolest people
on the internet i'm a huge fan of them
both and we're going to have them
together and we're going to be playing
heave ho which is i played a bit of and
it is chaos
um and we're just going to try and have
a nice conversation and you can donate
for anyone who has donated already thank
you so much we super appreciate it
for everyone else please use the link
tinyurl.com for slash play for all 2021
and you can donate to an incredibly
important cause we're going to see you
back here
very very soon 2 pm pt and we'll be
myself
lucy superior perch wolf and hvammer guy
if you're not already following jake
follow him on twitter
check where you at tell the people where
they can find you
me you can find me uh on game ranks
during the day
and at night youtube.com jake baldino
where i just talk about
stuff i love and ben where you at
you can find me on twitter.com uh
benjanka
i apologize in advance
[Laughter]
we'll see you in a couple of hours
everyone take